thought about what you were going to
wear for those holiday parties or family
photos don't worry we have you covered
hailey herzinski from downtown summerlin
joins us with a few festive inspired
looks haley thank you so much for being
here thank you i love shopping at
downtown summerlin and you guys have a
little bit of something for everyone so
it's not too late right if you're still
looking for a holiday outfit absolutely
if that last minute invite comes around
or you haven't had a chance to go out
shopping we have something for everybody
we have brand new retailers like
anthropology urban outfitters free
people so we're just excited you know to
be able to offer everything as a
one-stop shop yeah and the decor is
still up so you can really feel like
you're in the holiday spirit as you're
looking for your outfits but you have
some models here with us today to show
us a few inspired looks so i say we
bring them out absolutely we will start
with bridget come on out bridget you
look great i'm loving the sparkle so
it's always fun to add a little sparkle
we all love sparkles for holidays and
new years and this is just sort of like
a little bit of casual look you know if
you're just going to a friend's house
for a party you can layer all the time
layering super and style right now and
this is just a pop of color you know a
lot of times you have your metallic
sequins but this is just fun and paired
with a cute little pair of jeans um head
to toe from anthropology you got to give
us a little pose or strike a pose yes so
cute all right i'm loving this look
anthropology has some of the best stuff
absolutely it's a great place to shop
for holiday gifts and for outfits all
right let's bring out our next model
here we're talking about the men's
fashion now yes so we have keith in and
he is wearing head to toe dillards and
you know what i love about this look is
sort of mixing up the texture so he has
the velvet jacket with the
merino pants which is a different
pattern as well so you don't have to
stay safe you don't have to do the black
on black
and always paired with a white t-shirt
kind of makes it a little bit casual um
and fun for holiday parties i have to
tell you this outfit's making me really
happy because my husband has this exact
blazer and i put a white shirt under it
over the weekend for him so at least i
kind of know what i'm doing but
if you don't know what you're doing this
is a great idea and you can head over to
dillard's you guys have like a bunch of
different velvet colored lasers there so
you can pick whatever color you want
yeah whichever whichever you're feeling
that nice all right i see a pop of pink
out of the corner of my eye so now we're
talking color yes so we have no well
here and so this book is from jolene
which is a local retailer for women's
fashion um and it's a great place to
shop for a night out um and here again
with the pop of color and not
necessarily playing it safe you know we
have a metallic pant um when the wide
leg is in and so this is just something
great you can throw on a jacket
and attend a holiday party a new year's
eve party and you're good to go yeah we
don't have to play it safe during the
holidays this is fun i'm loving the
sparkle and the pop of color you got a
little bit of everything here and i want
to bring all of our models back in and
as they're coming in real quick hey if
you have a cute outfit on you want to go
out to dinner all of your restaurants
are open through the holidays right that
is correct our restaurants are open all
season long with great dining and we
have new restaurants like lanetta we
have players locker which is always
really fun and so you can just come down
make a night of it and then to get ready
for the holidays we have places like
summerhouse sparkles beauty bar sephora
so we can just get you dolled up and
ready to go it really is a one-stop shop
and you can come in your sequins get a
spray tin at the end of the night have
dinner i mean that's my kind of night so
yeah haley thank you so much for
breaking it down downtown summerlin is
always festive and we always love
spending the holidays there thank you
thank you i'll send it over to you
mercedes
great